[موسيقى]
دخل بالمغسله واثار معه الشك والريبه الى
ان تحقق التنبؤات هذا اللغز لكن يبدو ان
القادم اعظم
قضيه الثمانيه دولارات لا مفر منها لان
هذه التسعيره الشهريه مقابل وضع العلامه
الزرقاء على الحسابات الموثقه دخلت حيز
التنفيذ في الولايات المتحده وكندا
واستراليا ونيوزيلندا والمملكه المتحده
ورغم كل ما يجري فان الماسك متمسك
باجراءته التي يراها الافضل فهو عازم ايضا
على انهاء زمن لقطات الشاشه التي وصفها
بالسخيفه معلنا ان عصر النصوص الطويله
والمقاطع التي يصل وقتها الى اكثر من نصف
ساعه وبدقه عاليه سيظهر في الشهر المقبل
الملياردير الامريكي الذي طرد نصفه موظفي
وتر مظن في خطواته لانتقادات توقفه هو
الانقطاع الانفاق الاعلاني من كبر الشركات
يهز عرشاه ووفق صحيفه الفاينشل تايمز فانا
ماسك يمر بفتره الانتقاليه قرر خلالها ان
يحيطها نفسه بمجموعه مساعدين مخلصين
وموثوق بهم في غرفه الحرب السريه التي كان
فيها ذراعه الايمن والايسر شخصان يدعان
جيسون كلك اسود
اما مؤسسه تويتر جاك دورسي الذي شارك في
انشاء الشبكه الاجتماعيه عام 2006 غادرها
قبل سنه يبدو انه يرجح كفه ماسك التي
اختارت اقاله الموظفين على ان تنهار
الشركه الزرقاء تدريجيا بمقدار اربعه
ملايين يوميا لكنه في ذات الوقت قدم
اعتذارا مغلفا بقلب ازرق
ماسك الواثق بحلوله هو بالفعل غير مدرك ان
الامور معقده اكثر مما يظن هكذا يراه
بروسلي الذي شغل سابقا نائب رئيس تويتر
عبر عن صدمته بملك المنصه الجديد قائلا ان
قائلا لا يعرف ما الذي يفعله ويثير
بتصرفاته غير الديمقراطيه قلق الجميع
اسراء الصغير العربيه